Please welcome corporate executive
officer, corporate vice president,
COO in charge of solution services and head of
global solutions at Fujitsu, Yoshinami Takahashi.
[Music] Uh hi everyone. Uh my name is Takashi
from Fujitsu. Um basically I want to talk about
what we do with Palantia um in Japan. not only in
Japan but also like um across the globe we work
with trying to uh provide transformation to all
the industry countries. So Fujitsu is a Japanese
one of the largest tech company. We focus we built
like a supercomputer a quantum computing not not
air conditioning by the way. Um we're known we're
like a big one of the largest system integrator.
We focus on the mission critical either it
may be healthcare like a finance but this is
very important. So uh through our global brand
called Fujitsu Yubas, we're committed to kind
of solve the society issues and again turning
data in AI into better decisions and real world
outcomes. This is very important. So again with
Palantia we focus on the mission critical again
very critical to Japanese competitiveness. So we
focus again in like uh enterprise customers but
like a manufacturing, automotive, energy and also
like uh healthcare and these are really important.
So this uh many of these sectors do face a lot of
change challenges not only unique to Japan but I'm
sure all these multinational companies outside of
Japan do face similar kind of um problems like in
Japan by 2045 there's like a reduction of labor
force by almost 30 30%. That's a big number. So
we're going to face shortage of labor as you know
we have an earthquake in Japan. So that's pretty
immense what's happening in the earthquake all
the geopolitical issues that's happening across
the globe that's another issue. So in this kind of
uncertainty we are leveraging Palantius technology
and also Fujitsu's technology to kind of mitigate
all the risk. Uh since um how to say uh also one
more point this is very important uh we've been
using palantia for almost five years. So we have
like a 60 siloed system in Fujitsu. So we all
integrated the data through ontology making sure
we can make a right decision a global deci making
a right decision for business. So this type of
practice internal practice we take to our customer
as a firsthand experience. This is very important.
So last year in 2024 AIPCON my colleague has
talked about like the supply chain. So this
year we have moved this dynamic supply chain
management oper operating system using embedded
AI more into like advanced level. So what I want
to show you today is a live demonstration of what
we have right now and also what is coming up with
the new uh AI agents. So this is kind of a typical
uh example of like a Japanese global manufacturer.
They have like a 3,000 suppliers, 18 factories,
scattered system around 20. So they have obviously
issue around data fragmentation 200,000 SKU. So
basically the company was struggling with the
inventory management. So what we did is basically
um in two weeks with Panantia without shutting
down the existing uh system we built this global
supply chain system and also made the data into uh
visi visible so that the company can engage into
the transformation. So now they almost manage two
million parts simultaneously with Palantia Foundry
with our AI platform Kosichi again auto machine
learning we built a connected supply chain system
with 30 integrated application across inventory
forecasting and production and planning. So
in just two months kosuchi is again auto machine
learning the we built like a 300 demand prediction
for 300 SKUs. Because of this the company was able
to reduce the labor force by 50%. And now they
have this annual cost saving of over $10 million.
So how is this basically possible is again
uh this we did not base it on a single application
not a dashboard but also like this is like a truly
integrated dynam dynamic supply chain management
operating system. Again we think um uh solving
this kind of a impact in societ um in resolving
this social issues but also business issue is very
important. So let me kind of show you how this
is in placed in action. So when we talk about the
dynamic supply chain management operating system,
we do not mean just like a visibility. It's about
how much the company can take quick actions
making or like a taking every um decisions in
a right timing. Address the risk before it happens
across like a production, logistics and customer
and consumers. Again the inventory control many of
the large Japanese companies still use spreadsheet
which is again an issue. So with this uh operating
system the entire process is automated all the
supply chain data flows into one connected
environment optimizing operations cutting cost
and also maintaining resilience. This is kind
of very important and today this automation is
evolving further with AI agents. When a shortage
risk appears, specialized agent for procurement,
inventory and sales each will be proposing a
solution. An orchestration a agent will kind of
select the best option and an evaluator agent will
validate the option. Then the human beings upon
necessity they will make decision collaboratory
with the AI agent. So again we think dynamic
supply chain like a 90 more than 95% of the task
should be automated. So this is not really in
theory but it's in practice right now with this
Japanese large companies right now in Japan.
Uh this capability and speed are only possible
because it's not a single application but a fabric
of over 30 interconnected applications
built on the same business ontology.
Once the ontology allows every new
application to reinforce for the others,
accelerating development and creating a shared
foundation where AI agents and human operators
collaborate seamlessly and result is not uh
just efficiency but also the resilience. So
as you as I kind of may maybe mentioned before
like Japan is like a country of earthquake. So
when not earthquake hit u uh in January of 2024
this company was able to kind of uh mitigate the
all the risks associated with supply chain. So
within like one day they were able to kind of
define what is the possible impact and they they
made a decision to reroot kind of change supply
on the spot. Usually it took like almost like a
four to like seven days. But through this kind
of ontology data integration and and leveraging
the AI they were able to do to to do this type of
um um crisis management. So again the true
supply chain we think it's like it's it needs
to be like a connected intelligent and ready
for both daily decisions and crisis response.
So building on that same foundation, we are
now taking it to the next level, embedding
AI agents directly into disaster response. The
real the reality is that this operating system
operating system not only works in the business
as usual, this is not enough. So in the modern
uh global supply chain, we believe it needs to
withstand variety of shocks. So again earthquakes
or like a tsunami or like a supplier failure or
even like a geopolitical dis disruption that can
break all the continuity with the business. So
together with palantia we developed this agents
to handle these complex scenarios. For example a
disaster response agent for large scale earthquake
earthquakes in Japan where like a magnitude 8 is
expected in next few decades. we have to be kind
of prepared for this type of uh uh incidents.
So this agent will be managing uh disruption,
simulating potential facility damage, assessing
inventory impact and also highlighting weak points
across the supply chain. So again supporting
not the day-to-day usage only but when at the
time of crisis how fast we can respond to this
type of um uh incidents. This is very important.
Uh another point is again um because our ontology
AIP and AI agents are unified on one platform.
The agent not only explains why they have made
that options but also turns this into the live
execution moving operators from insight to actions
instantly with confidence. This is very important.
So again uh one example around this is the like a
principle applies not only across like a a single
task but like a procurement production sales and
intercon connected of connect connectivity of AI
agents embedded directly into the operation.
So as I as I have mentioned the AI agent will
be developed and it's going to learn what how to
mitigate more risk in a more clever way. We think
this is uh very important moving forward. So then
the next step is going to be how do we train and
evolve the AI agents. So this is kind of a very
famous icon that we have made. So we have this
uh very domain specific agents working across
multiple task. So the uh rapid development of a AI
agent not is possible but practical practical at
scale. This is very important. So each time that
uh the agents face a disruption or unusual case
they learn from the feedback from human beings
and then based on their proposal the human beings
will be feeding back was that the right decision
was that effective decision and also validation
agent will be teaching all the uh co u domain
specific agent you could have maybe made a
different decision or option. So I think this
type of enterprise feedback loop with the data and
interaction between human beings that will be kind
of educating all the agents again auto machine
learning this type of technology will also support
the agents learn quickly about the uh incidents.
So more and more we think the agent itself is
going to be automated as we kind of leverage
this type of agents across multiple cases.
So one of the key element is that the AI agent
is going to be is going is going to grow like a
newborn to a very skilled professionals over time.
So again they do not learn like a task by the
explicit rules but also by subtle decision making
that is unique to each company and because this
uh capability is embedded in the operating
system. It scales allowing organization to
continuously advance the dynamic supply
chain shared by their own expertise.
So um this type of like u the agent learning
from each other being educated as a skilled
worker we think there's going to be a
rapid development of AI agents in this
uh segment. Uh our vision with palante goes beyond
this single case. We think this AI agent is going
to reside in a single usage for a moment like
within a company. But over time the agent will
talk to each other with a cross company and
that will kind of give more impact resolving
many of the society issues. Again imagine one of
the manufacturers of all the suppliers sharing
data they can uh they can all basically manage
the disruption in a more managed way. Imagine
this agent is talking into cross industry
for like a energy company. How to kind of
um ensure that the electricity is u provided to
the needed factory. So when the data is shared
we think we can provide much more biggest
resilience to the society itself. So our
vision is to kind of leverage technology again
palantia and fujitsu coming together to kind of
u to make sure we have a very robust uh system in
the Japan society. But we basically want to kind
of provide this type of solution across the uh not
only in Japan but also across the global market.
So that is uh my presentation today and thank you
very much for the attention. Thank you so much.